[Music]
oh man i love uh articles i get to show
you guys something gross you just showed
us something yeah yeah yeah yeah to be
honest is it better or worse
than the last one this one might be
worse i can't look oh
hey the last one went on patreon only so
where's this mike almost threw up
i didn't know i think the idea of this
one is worse i don't even think this is
a patreon i think this is like safe but
i oh god show me it's oh okay i see and
it's not it's not in the headlight is it
a [ __ ] arrow through someone's head
like a [ __ ]
bro we saw a titty explode and you think
of arrows
that's pretty huge decrepit jitty
that's an
this is irreversible alien tint yeah all
right so listen to this
a 28 year old texas woman who was
struggling to lose weight
discovered that the cause of the
difficulty
was a 20-pound tumor growing on her
ovary which was filled with hair and
teeth
yo okay how does that happen is that a
baby how do tubers have hair and teeth
on it because that does happen i think
it's a baby she was growing [ __ ]
cousin it dude don't people like uh
actually get born with like heads right
here or like some weird [ __ ] like when
you're getting black
right here
yeah wherever oh you're gonna show us
the tumor [ __ ] yeah they took it out
yeah what is he causing it it might be a
baby so it's 20 pounds
and it's growing on our overlapping
that's big
two baby boxes oh what is that that
doesn't freak me out that much because i
don't know what it is yeah i don't know
what it is they gotta crack it open dude
but they need to put like a quarter next
to it or something so you know wait i
need to see that [ __ ] up close that
looks like an alien egg sack
that looks like an alien egg they need
to pop it open dude where's the teeth
you said hair and teeth too
but they cut it open probably was it
like half alive how's it grossing it's
blinking at me
[Laughter]
so the thing that's crazy is um did she
think she was pregnant so it was sucking
all the nutrients like she would eat and
then um all of the useful like nutrients
would go to that tumor and it would just
grow and grow no way you feel good right
like she has to feel off oh yeah she
felt like [ __ ] but look at this i mean
this is nice too like look at her weight
loss glow up
before and after
that's
put your squat on mommy
it's a great story so like i'm proud of
you yeah alien tit was not a good story
this is a guess
yeah it's great because like once they
found out that's what was causing it she
dropped like 103 pounds or something
yeah maybe that's my issue too yeah
maybe we all have two ways on our
ovaries
your ovaries are [ __ ] up man
yeah look let's give it up again look at
that nice
well she became asian
wow
she became asian not only did she glow
up into a skinny girl but an asian girl
she went from a mexican chick to eight
up to that tumor again 20 pounds
shout out to the tumor that's like the
new weight loss program find your tumor
with teeth on it
every fat person's running their doctor
i think i got a tumor i think i have
what she has
yeah so uh was it a tumor or was it a
baby well here's the part that here's
your
the part that disturbed me was so they
they kind of were looking into what it
could have really been yeah
and they think that what happened was
when she was born
she actually had a twin in the womb shut
the [ __ ] up whoa and then what happened
was because there was a weird
abnormality where that twin might have
just like that's [ __ ] voldemort might
have absorbed it
yeah you know that happens we're like
yeah they fight quinn absorbs the other
[Laughter]
yeah so she might have absorbed her twin
and then that is the remnant of like her
twin the twin was just like sucking
nutrients trying to stay alive oh [ __ ]
so she was actually a siamese girl she's
a siamese gal just chick dude dan you
think after her though like you think
she had like voices in her head too and
then suddenly she cut that out and now
she's like
you think that's just real what twins
talking about like feeling each other's
pain and [ __ ]
you know
you think that's real only if they feel
each other's joy as well you know what i
mean during sex you know
so the reason they really they think
that is because she comes from a family
lineage of a lot of twins so they're
like oh dude that seems pretty practical
then but isn't it common when you get a
tumor you just grow weird [ __ ] things
in it like an eyeball or some [ __ ] and
you're like because it's the genetics
the programming of it like the dna was
like oh make an eye here make an ear
here and it's like that's a shoulder bro
she's like a creative character for like
a video game yeah that's all [ __ ] up
it's got bugs yeah that's all it's a
mutating
mutated mr potato yeah it's a mutating
when you say that the the tumor was
sucking up the nutrients that's when i'm
like that's a [ __ ] being right there
you know what i mean selfish and why is
it yeah right
like needs you know it's got the
survival mode of it that needs to like
feed in order to stay alive you know
what i'm saying yeah and she was she was
sad because she thought because he had
to take it out that
she wouldn't be able to have kids
because it was on her ovary but yeah but
they said that all the eggs are just
going to move to the other side
of kids yeah that's pretty crazy yeah
isn't that awesome
her kids are going to be asian or what
is she asian no she doesn't think she's
like an abg all of a sudden what the
[ __ ] that
asian baby girl man the [ __ ] is that
what asian baby girl her name is jamie
conwell what's that hot asian so she
went from white to asian like this like
90s thing where a bunch of girls you
know asian asian girls like had this
it's called asian baby girl right yeah
they have this motif that yeah crazy
eyelashes you ever see an asian chick
with blonde hair and her roots are
growing out she smokes cigarettes
wearing a spaghetti strap and like
fighting everybody no but i think i get
it yeah yeah you get the vibe ask david
david's abg he's from sacramento he'll
tell you we're always sucking on
lollipops they're out there
sitting on honda civics bamboo hoop
earrings yeah
they have the lipstick with the line
outside they kind of resemble chola
sometimes but typically they don't have
sometimes they got the house arrest ink
lit on oh oh damn i like dangerous women
that's an asian baby girl but yeah isn't
that crazy that she lost that much
weight she weighs 147 now and she was uh
what was it 2 50. i want to see her
start doing tumor commercials tumor
commercials like i had ovarian tumors
and look at what i used to look like and
look at me now
i can only think of like lizards and
stuff but there's snakes straight with
two heads that are both alive yeah yeah
like humans get that like we're joking
about voldemort but but there is there
ever been one that's alive yeah humans
got that like the two heads are like
stuck to each other type thing they like
these twins like this or whatever when
they always have shows on tlc and
they're alive yeah they're both talking
to each other like this oh yeah those
are that one that freaks me out there's
two girls yeah yeah and then some of
them even talk about having sex yeah
well but they're they're joined like
here right they're not like just two
heads and i have no clue it's scary no
no it's not like a singular body and two
different heads into the person well you
know let me see the google sometimes
sometimes it's just an extra head like
here that's like dead i've seen that i
didn't but there's something oh these
yeah it's these
i don't like that dude
why not i don't like that at all i don't
know you gotta look at it mike look you
gotta look at it you gotta get over here
not
like this right here they share a body
yeah they share the body but the brain
reality show but the brains are both
rocking on their own yeah
yeah two separate ways i wonder if
monsters increase they talk about the
logistics of living with each other and
like having boyfriends
what if i make you wipe my ass because i
don't want to use this hand you got to
use your hand only so it's like two
people with one body and they gotta like
i don't like that dude that really
scares me
yeah that scares me i'm i'm wondering
who has control over what limb well or
what do you feel like do you what if i
got a poop
so they got two spinal cords probably
right yeah that's that's what it's about
the right brain
famous old asian people that chang
bunker that's that was called siamese
twist
i thought that's called tango now
they're now they're all old and [ __ ]
it's the same guys wow like that that
kind of i get it like maybe your skin
just kind of didn't separate them that
one's a little bit like you don't share
one body you're just connected at the
end and if they were born in 2020 they
can probably surgery yeah those girls
they share a body or the guys poopers
are
yeah if you guys if you guys ended up
like having a conjoined twin and they
said we can try to separate them but one
might die would you go for it i'm doing
it dude no i'm giving my brother a life
you're gonna die well if like that's the
worst case yeah but then what if he dies
i'd be very sad see but then at least
i'd be free no
i'm like nah we're buddies dude i mean
if you're used to it if you're used to
it then you don't know what independence
feels like yeah that is what you grew up
i mean like if you as a parent yeah the
parents are making the call and then the
doctor's parents
hey looks like you had your twins came
out but they're stuck together we can
try to save one oh yeah chop one of them
off before you can finish the sentence i
got a butcher knife and i cut that's
exactly the medical terminology a little
bit less mouth to face yeah which one's
prettier oh geez
what's the kaiser permanente policy on
this
they're like we don't cover this here
how common is that i can't be confident
one in three
what no
one i hope to god the one that i save is
an [ __ ] it's gonna be like one in
three million yeah
and what's even the rate of twins
less than one percent whoops if you're
conjoined twins can you use the carpool
lane yes
i think you get a lot of [ __ ] dude like
you should [ __ ] go to disneyland for
free yeah honestly joint twins occur
once in every 50 to 60 000 births
that's not even that much it's not
that's like one a day
and 70 of the conjoined twins are female
70
is there a reason why this happens is
there like a genetic
predisposition that like can be
identifiable or is it just like we don't
know didn't eat enough wheaties that's
crazy i didn't know is that common i'm
sure yeah
i'm sorry if i heard nobody's feeling
it's also crazy that there's varying
degrees of how conjoined they are yeah
like the other one you just showed the
lower halves are joined it looks like
it's here the other one wears four legs
yeah so they're full they're fully
developed lower half and this one is
like you consume the baby inside and now
they're on your uterus
the girls on the tv show they just have
two legs no they just have two heads
yeah that's what i mean but like two
normal legs they share one body
everything else is like normal that's
crazy and then they i think they it's
like divided imagine the pain though
like we get pain from bad posture and
[ __ ] yeah all right but do you think
they're constantly holding each other up
though so it's like it's not that bad it
looks like they have a pretty cool light
one's head's like this yeah this gotta
hurt the left side of your head and so
she's like how come i get how come you
get to be the straight neck like how
come like can we trade
because maybe she's doing this to be
like nice like when you're in do you
think
she's an airplane it's kind of like this
right
do you think do you think that when
you're like that though it's kind of
like how come you're like there's
jealousy or is it like we are one yeah i
can't be jealous of my left arm and how
do they fight it i [ __ ] hit each
other on their head like [ __ ] you
[ __ ] yeah they're like yeah
yeah
would you feel it oh if i hit stop if i
hit him in the head they stopped
laughing because you punch your shoulder
nick stop laughing dude
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you